[Musik]
Heizung Haushalt Abschwung Ampel im
krisenmodus das fragen wir uns an diesem
Donnerstagabend klasse dass sie wieder
mit dabei sind liebe Zuschauer
monatelang hat sich die Ampel und
eigentlich das ganze Land über dieses
heizungsgesetz gestritten nach der
Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes gestern geht
das Ding nun in eine neue Runde welch
eine Niederlage für die Regierung der
Wahl kämpfen die Bürger mit den hohen
Preisen die Unternehmen auch und alle
zusammen mit einem Abschwung der
hoffentlich nicht chronisch wird der
Bundeskanzler sieht alles auf
Deutschland zulaufen ja aber nicht viel
Gutes würde der Bürger sagen wir müssen
reden mit diesen Gästen
die Parteivorsitzende der Grünen Ricarda
lang
Alexander Dobrindt CSU landesgruppenchef
die Vorsitzende des DGB Jasmin
die Wirtschaftsweise Ulrike malmedia
Dagmar Rosenfeld Chefredakteurin Welt am
Sonntag
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner und
die begrüßt alle gestern noch mal
ausgesprochen herzlich los geht's vor
der parlamentarischen Sommerpause sollte
es verabschiedet werden dass Gebäude
Energiegesetz und dann kam der Knall von
gestern ab
Thomas Heilmann von der CDU sah seine
Rechte als Abgeordneter verletzt und
klagte mit Erfolg eine
Verfassungsbeschwerde zu diesem Gesetz
kommen zu sicher wie das Arm in der
Kirche insofern habe ich der Ampel aus
meiner Sicht ein Gefallen getan das
Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts ist
eine schwere Niederlage für die
Bundesregierung von Olaf Scholz
die Ampel ist blamiert war sie seit
Beginn der Debatte zu viel blieb zu
lange unklar zu viel Brechstange zu
wenig Substanz zwischen der Vorlage des
Gesetzes also den den ersten Monaten
dieses Jahres und heute ist natürlich
etwas passiert in Deutschland und das
habe ich oder wir nicht rechtzeitig
bemerkt da wo der Vizekanzler nur ein
zeitliches Problem sieht er kennt die
SPD den echten Schaden das darf uns
nicht noch einmal passieren das haben
glaube ich auch alle verstanden in der
Koalition das hätte nicht passieren
dürfen das auch nur der Eindruck
entsteht da werden funktionierende
Heizsysteme rausgerissen das tut mir
leid
auch ganz persönlich täte es ihm leid
sagte Kevin Kühnert dass da eine solche
Verunsicherung bei den Menschen
entstanden ist Ricarda lang ist bei uns
eine der zwei schäfinnen der Grünen Frau
lang der
Kevin Kühnert Generalsekretär SPD hat
sich persönlich entschuldigt haben sie
irgendwann zwischendurch mal gedacht
dass es eigentlich auch ganz schlau wäre
wenn die Gründe das täten ich kann das
für mich auf jeden Fall auch sagen
natürlich tut es auch mir leid dass wir
als Ampel es nicht geschafft haben bei
diesem wichtigen Thema das ja für die
Zukunft des Landes so zentral ist genug
Sicherheit zu geben sondern das ist viel
öffentlichen Streit gab dass die soziale
Frage nicht von Anfang geklärt war und
das so auch falsche Eindrücke entstanden
werden es war immer klar es wird keine
funktionierende Heizung rausgerissen
aber ist der Eindruck entstanden ist ist
ein Problem und das tut auch mir leid
gestern von dieser Entscheidung waren
sie überrascht oder haben sie damit
schon gerechnet dass er heimlich
durchsetzen könnte
ich habe das erstmal abgewartet und am
Ende entscheiden zu einer Situation das
Bundesverfassungsgericht sind ich glaube
wir müssen es anschauen was die
Entscheidung genau bedeutet das ist
keine Entscheidung bis Inhalt des
Gesetzes sondern über das Verfahren aber
da ist ganz klar die respektieren diese
Entscheidung wir nehmen das sehr ernst
das haben ja die Fraktion sich heute
auch entschieden dass jetzt in der
ersten September Sitzungswoche dann
final über das Gebäude Energiegesetz
entschieden wird als das jetzt auch ein
bisschen Ruhe in Verfahren eingebracht
wird und gleichzeitig dass man gemeinsam
hinter dem Entwurf steht der viel
diskutiert wurde in der Regierung der in
den Ausschüssen schon beschlossen wurde
und das so einbringen und dann auch
abstimmen wird also dass man trotzdem
eine Planungssicherheit hat für die
Handwerke für die Unternehmen für die
BürgerInnen Dagmar Rosenfeld ist bei uns
Chefredakteurin der Welt Frau Hosenfeld
der wenn man den Bundeskanzler dazu hört
sagt er er ist einverstanden mit diesem
Verfahren die Bundesregierung die
Minister sind einverstanden mit diesem
Verfahren jetzt wann glauben Sie war da
wer programmiert alle überrascht also
ich bin mir sicher dass alle überrascht
waren weil am Mittwochabend war SPD
Hoffest da sah man offenbar einen
ausgelassenen fröhlichen Kanzler der
schon in Urlaubsstimmung war und um 21
Uhr 48 kam dann die ersten Meldungen
über Agenturen wie Karlsruhe entschieden
hat und offenbar hat es ja keinen Plan B
gegeben der wurde jetzt heute schnell
verhandelt dass man sagt es war ja nicht
klar macht man in der Sommerpause eine
Sondersitzung oder schiebt man es auf
nach die Sommerpause man hat sich für
letzteres entschieden nur das ändert am
Verfahren nichts und die Frage die ich
mir stelle und die die Ampel bisher
nicht beantworten konnte ist warum
dieser Eile bei diesem Gesetzesverfahren
dafür gibt es keine sachliche Begründung
es gibt politische Erwägungen also die
Grünen brauchten vielleicht auch mal
einen Erfolg oder man wollte diesen
monatelangen Streit vergessen machen
oder anstehende Landtagswahlen im Herbst
und das sind alles aber keine Gründe
Geschichte des Parlaments zu verletzen
und das hat die Ampel getan wie
Karlsruhe jetzt geurteilt hat und ich
möchte die Ampel an ihre eigenen
Maßstäbe erinnern also im
Koalitionsvertrag der Ampel steht dass
man den das Parlament als Ort der
Debatte und der Gesetzgebung stärken
wolle und das Parlament frühzeitig
einbinden wolle genau das Gegenteil ist
aber passiert und mich würde
interessieren warum die eine bei diesem
Gesetz vor lang ganz kurz dazu kann ich
ja gerne was sagen es ging tatsächlich
darum Planungssicherheit zu schaffen das
ist ja was worauf sich die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger einstellen müssen zum
Beispiel auf die Frage wie viel soziale
Förderung bekomme ich muss die
Handwerker darauf einstellen müssen die
Unternehmen die jetzt passieren
gleichzeitig als Parlamentarierin kann
ich auch ganz klar sagen das war jetzt
kein Glanzstück deshalb ist es glaube
ich gut wenn man jetzt Ruhe ins
Verfahren einbringen und auch als Ampel
sagt natürlich sollte sowas nicht noch
mal passieren also ich bin zwei Punkte
richtig stellen die Förderrichtlinie
steht ja immer noch nicht die kommt erst
im September da frage ich mich auch
warum warum das zust Ministerium bis
September Zeit bekommt aber das Gesetz
jetzt schon vor der Sommerpause durch
soll das finde ich den ein Punkt und
Planungssicherheit es hängt doch alles
noch von der wärmeplanung ab die kommt
2026 für große Städte für kleinere
Kommunen 2028 da ist doch noch gar keine
Planungssicherheit da ich finde man
müsste einen Schritt nach dem anderen
gehen erst die wärmeplanung und dann ein
Gebäude Energiegesetz das Gesetz wird ja
im ersten ersten 20 24 in Kraft treten
und dann stückweise gekoppelt an die
wärmeplanung was ich auch sinnvoll finde
ich glaube damit haben wir jetzt noch
mal ein Stück pragmatischer gemacht den
Leuten auch mehr Zeit gegeben aber die
Grundsatzentscheidung also den Einstieg
in der erneuerbare Wärme der wird früher
getroffen und dann sagt man dort wo es
eine kommunale wärmeplanung gibt wird es
daran
Zeit man muss es ja erstmal erfahren
Frau lang ob man jetzt eine kommunale
wärmeplanung vorliegen hat oder nicht
und ob man also Empfänger von Fernwärme
wäre oder nicht so richtig verstehen
kann man es noch nicht ich freue mich
dass man zu meiner Linken Alexander
doberin sitzt der
CSU Vertreter im Deutschen Bundestag
Fraktions Vize der Unionsfraktion Herr
Dobrind wenn Sie auf diese Situation
jetzt gucken die Ampel sagt sie möchte
eigentlich nichts verändern es soll Zeit
geben bis zum September rot gelb und
grün sind einverstanden mit dem was da
auf dem Tisch liegt sind sie ist auch
oder sagen Sie wir März wir würden gerne
mit euch reden und kommen euch auch
entgegen
also mit dem Inhalt kann man nicht
zufrieden sein aber in der Tat hat er
das Verfassungsgericht jetzt erstmal
nicht den Inhalt bewertet sondern den
Prozess und das war natürlich eine
richtige Klatsche für die Ampel aber vor
allem für den Politikstil für die
Arroganz mit der man mit diesem Thema
umgeht maximale Verunsicherung
geschaffen dann dieses Projekt mehrmals
verändert neu geschrieben und dann
letzte Woche am Freitag
110 Seiten quasi komplett anderes Gesetz
vorlegen und dem Bundestag darüber nicht
mehr beraten lassen wollen und wenn man
schon eingesteht dass da eine hohe
Verunsicherung in der Bevölkerung da ist
die auch übrigens nach wie vor da ist
die übrigens auch erstmal bleiben wird
weil eben die wärmeplanung des Gesetz
kommt erst im Herbst weil die
Förderrichtlinie die soll erst im Herbst
kommen jetzt werden Teile davon bekannt
da stellt man fest dass die Prozentzahl
mit 70% Förderung sowas alles überhaupt
nicht zutrifft am Schluss dann wenn es
um die Euro Beträge geht was dann eine
Deckelung gibt
bei den 70% 21 bei der Regel wird es
15.000 sein was maximal an Förderung da
ist und die Leute werden 50 60 70.000
Euro ausgeben müssen und nur 15.000
bekommen das schafft jetzt wieder
Verunsicherung weil es einfach nicht auf
dem Tisch liegt und jetzt in dieser
Phase dann zu glauben man könnte so ein
Gesetz was in Wahrheit niemand versteht
bisher und der Bundestag nicht beraten
kann dadurch zu peitschen das ist diese
Arroganz die kritisiert wird und
deswegen hat zu Recht das
Verfassungsgerichte gesagt ein
Bundestagsabgeordneter hat nicht nur das
Recht abzustimmen sondern hat auch das
Recht ein Gesetz zu beraten und diese
Möglichkeit muss gegeben werden und die
ist schlichtig nicht gegeben worden und
ich bin mir eigentlich sicher dass sie
darüber diskutiert haben und wissentlich
diesen Weg gegangen sind der jetzt vorm
verfassungsgespräche intern auch
diskutiert erstmal unter den drei Ampel
sein welchen Weg sie eigentlich gehen
wollen jasmin fahimi ist bei uns die
Chefin ist die Gebet des Deutschen
Gewerkschaftsbundes Robert habe haben
inzitiert hat bedauert den falschen
Zeitpunkt gefunden zu haben für die
Ausrufung dieses Gesetzes es wäre viel
einfacher gewesen in 22 als wir uns alle
noch sorgten ob wir genug Gas hätten für
den Winter kann es einen schlechten oder
einen richtigen Zeitpunkt geben für ein
handwerklich so schlecht gemacht das
Gesetz ja das ist ja fast eine
rhetorische Frage aber ich glaube den
Zeitpunkt und die Vorhabenplanung der
einzelnen Verabredungen
Koalitionsvertrag das muss die
Bundesregierung am Ende untereinander
ausmachen das kann ja so oder so
beurteilen ich wundere mich ein bisschen
über die verschiedene Eskalationen
dieses Konfliktes also dass das alles
andere als geschickt war dass das eine
kommunikative Katastrophe gewesen ist
und das würde ich nicht nur einer Seite
zuschieben wollen dass man über einen
Referentenentwurf Wochen lang in der
Öffentlichkeit diskutiert das ist
einfach schlechtes Politik Management
ich glaube da muss man überhaupt nichts
besch
es gibt Verfahren wie
Ressortabstimmungen laufen man sollte
sich auch vorzeitiger mit Stakeholdern
also mit Betroffenen halt auch
auseinandersetzen nicht erst nicht erst
über die Belastung reden und dann
Entlastung hinterherschieben das hätte
man alles viel viel ruhiger machen
können das wäre wünschenswert gewesen
jetzt hat es Verbesserungen gegeben
jetzt hat es eine Einigung gegeben
aber wir diskutieren eigentlich kaum
mehr über den Inhalt des Gesetzes
sondern über den Streit das finde ich
ziemlich lächerlich und das finde ich
auch nicht hilfreich für ich sag mal die
Orientierungshilfe die die Menschen
eigentlich von der Bundesregierung aber
auch von den Medien erwartet
und dass wir jetzt noch dass wir jetzt
anfangen über den Streit des Streits zu
diskutieren wird wirklich langsam absurd
also ich würde uns empfehlen dass wir
über andere wichtige Themen jetzt reden
die Inhalte sind verabredet dass die
Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgericht ist ein rein
eine reine Entscheidung Gesetz also
absolut ich finde das auch finde das
finde ich auch absolut berechtigt aber
es geht nicht um die Inhalte die in
Frage gestellt worden sind sondern das
bleibt halt am Ende jetzt die
Entscheidung des Parlamentes aber
politisch bleiben natürlich noch in
Frage gestellt für sie aber
offensichtlich nicht für die Regierung
also wir hätten auch noch
Verbesserungsvorschläge so ist es nicht
ja aber ich gehe davon aus ohne dass ich
jetzt hier zu viel
nicht aus dem Fenster lehnen will aber
meine Prognose wäre da passiert nicht
mehr viel aber wenn aber wenn
dramatische Fehler aber
interessiert daran auch noch mal gehört
zu werden also dein offensichtlich
auch Arbeitnehmer und ihre Kollegen
damit ausgesprochen und zufrieden
gewesen auch als Bürger verfolgen zu
müssen was die Politik da liefert und
jeden Tag neu mit der nächsten Botschaft
in den Wald geschickt zu werden wo man
sich jetzt mit Energieberater und
anderen sonst ins Benehmen setzen weil
ich will natürlich eine inhaltliche
Frage stellen und freue mich Eure
gemeinsame in der Sendung zu begrüßen
sie ist eine der Wirtschaftsweisen
dieses Landes und sie haben tollerweise
die Expertise auch für Amerika weil sie
in Berkley Lehren hätte es in ihren
Augen in den Augen einer Ökonomen
denn zu diesem
Gebäude Energiegesetz so wie wir es
jetzt auf dem Tisch zu liegen haben eine
Alternative gegeben beispielsweise über
diese CO2 Bepreisung
ja wir Ökonomen reden immer sehr gerne
über das first best ideale Lösung und da
wäre der Preismechanismus noch nicht
ganz oben als ein Wirkungsmechanismus
den wir gerne benutzen würden ja also
das CO2 Preise und die aktive Nutzung
Sinn machen würde das stimmt auf jeden
Fall für Deutschland das stimmt für die
USA umso mehr Kalifornien sieht ein
bisschen besser aus aber das ist ja
eigentlich nicht die Frage die Frage ist
ja was das sogenannte second best wie
wir Ökonomen das nennen die das
implementiert werden kann und da gibt es
halt politische Zwänge da gibt es eine
Ampelkoalition für verschiedene
Interessen zusammenkommen und da gibt's
natürlich auch den Umstand dass das
jetzt was ganz Neues ist was umgesetzt
wird es ist ein altes Problem das muss
man ja auch mal sagen das konnte man
hätte man schon seit Jahrzehnten aber
bearbeiten können das wird jetzt endlich
bearbeitet aber es wird jetzt ganz ganz
neues implementiert und das wird halt
nicht immer ganz glatt gehen das ist
nicht so als ob sich jetzt mal die
Milchpreise Supermarkt ändern nein wir
versuchen jetzt wirklich das
Gleichgewicht zu verschieben nennen
würden und da wird es natürlich Friktion
geben da wird es natürlich ein
Perfektion geben sicherlich alle
Beteiligten haben wir hier gesagt das
hätte besser laufen können also darum
darum geht es jetzt hier nicht aber ich
würde mir sehr wünschen um meinen Punkt
von premi aufzugreifen dass wir den
Inhalt weiter im Vordergrund behalten
also was können wir jetzt ändern um für
den Klimaschutz was zu tun und dann aus
diesem Streit hätte ich mir auch
gewünscht die positiven Aspekte
rauszuziehen das war ja durchaus war
dass da soziale Verwerfung hätte geben
können dass vielleicht Aspekte welche
Schichten der Bevölkerung betroffen sind
nicht besonders gut bedacht wurden dass
da jetzt rauszunehmen aus dem Streit
darum Streit um den Streit zu machen das
wäre wunderschön und ich muss sagen ich
finde das funktioniert in Deutschland
immer noch besser als ich das in den USA
sehr oft sehe und ich würde mir sehr
wünschen dass wir das nicht völlig
verlieren und dennoch ist ja etwas
passiert in dem Land weil die Menschen
logischerweise auch in einer
trippelkrise sind die der Bundeskanzler
genauso festhält wie der Vizekanzler und
ist eine Opposition in diesem Land gibt
auch das gehört die hat dazu die
stumm läuft und zwar so deswegen werden
für uns auf abziehbare Zeit auch die
Grünen die Hauptgegner sein in dieser
Bundesregierung denn die Grünen sind
dafür verantwortlich dass diese
Polarisierung um die Energiepolitik um
die Umweltpolitik in Deutschland in
dieser Weise entstanden ist die FDP ist
auch in der Regierung eine totale
Enttäuschung die Freien Wähler reden
viele aber tun sich schwer was
umzusetzen die AFD sinnlos und die
Grünen echte ideologische Feind
echter ideologischer Feind sagt Markus
Söder sagt das auch Alexander Dobrindt
oder sagen Sie politischer Gegner also
nur um kurz die Sprache zu klären ich
habe keine romantischen Gefühle
gegenüber den Grünen also
mir auch nicht unterstellt und wir sind
im Wettbewerb natürlich wir sind alle
miteinander im Wettbewerb und da geht's
dann auch am Schluss über die
inhaltlichen Fragen und deswegen ist
eines klar wenn man so im Wettbewerb ist
machen sich die Unterschiede an so einem
Thema das so polarisiert und natürlich
auch so in einer Streitsituation
entstanden ist eine Ampel wie dieses
Gebäude energiegesetzter macht sich dann
noch mal sehr sehr deutlich aber sagen
die AFD sind diejenigen ist die Partei
mit der Sie sich am meisten
auseinandersetzen wollen um sie zu
halbieren wie Friedrich Merz mal
vorgeschlagen hat und auch vor hatte
warum jetzt ausgerechnet die Grünen
moment mal der die AFD ist der
politische Gegner Rechtsaußen eindeutig
überhaupt keine Frage und mit allen
anderen sind wir in Wettbewerb ich habe
nichts anderes an der Stelle gesagt und
das ist die Aufstellung wie wir sie
haben wir müssen unter den
demokratischen Parteien im Wettbewerb
sein und da wo die Demokratie aufhört da
beginnt die Gegnerschaft und das ist
Rechtsaußen an dieser Stelle deswegen
ist es sehr klar für mich definiert und
eine sehr klare Auseinandersetzung die
wir dafür führen müssen aber das führt
jetzt auch nicht dazu dass wir
inhaltlich dem was die Ampel vorgelegt
hat zustimmen können und deswegen bin
ich ja so irritiert dass nicht die Zeit
jetzt genutzt wird jetzt hat man doch
das Verfassungsgericht noch mal Zeit
bekommen über ein Gesetz zu reden auf
dem definitiv kein Segen liegt und man
kriegt heute mitgeteilt von den drei
Ampel Fraktionen dass sie genau dieses
Gesetz was sie diese Woche nicht
verabschieden haben dürfen im September
so verabschieden wollen das ist doch
wieder dieser Politikstil der weiter für
verdroht für Verärgerung sagt es ist
inhaltlich vieles nicht in Ordnung
nicht über den Inhalt dieses
gesetzesquote Halt sondern
wird jetzt ganz klar eingehalten aber
ich will zu dieser Frage von Gegner und
Feind einer was sagen weil für mich ist
ganz klar die demokratischen Parteien
das sind Mitbewerber das sind
Konkurrenten dass in meiner Partner aber
es sind keine Feinde Feinde sind die die
sich wirklich außerhalb des
demokratischen Spektrums orientieren und
deshalb würde ich mir wünschen ich würde
eigentlich sagen die hauptgegenden
Probleme im Land das sind die Probleme
in diesem Land also das ist die Frage
wie schaffen wir die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit das ist die Frage
wie schaffen wir mehr soziale
Gerechtigkeit wie kriegen wir das hin
mit dem Klimaschutz und dass man
eigentlich unter demokratischen Parteien
in Wettbewerb geht wer die besten Ideen
auf dem Weg dahin und dann muss er was
sagen Sie haben gerade USA angesprochen
es ist ja ein Glück dass wir gerade in
einem Land leben wo man nicht 50 50
erstmal aber die Frage diskutieren muss
existiert die Klimakrise sondern du hast
unter den demokratischen Parteien ein
gemeinsamen Konsens gibt es muss etwas
getan werden beim Klimaschutz und dann
würde ich mir wünschen dass wir uns
nicht gegen sie jetzt Feinde bezeichnen
man die AFD hohe Ergebnisse hat nicht
auf die anderen zeigen sondern diesen
Wettbewerb einsteigen so bitterer ist
doch Frau lang dass sie untereinander so
sehr darüber gestritten haben das ist
nicht nur die 107 Fragen gab und den
Vorwurf des Wortbruchs und oder die 97
Fragen sondern das ja auch ein ganz
zentrales versprechen und dann sind wir
bei den größeren Gedanken an zentrales
versprechen nämlich das im Zentrum auch
ihrer Politik das soziale stehen wollte
sie haben immer darauf verwiesen dass
diese Ricarda lang eigentlich auch aus
armen Verhältnissen kamen und dass sie
immer im Zentrum betrachten ihre Politik
haben wollten das ist den Menschen gut
geht in dem Land und dass sie mit einer
ordentlichen Arbeit diese lassen auch
gut leben können so genau die gehen
jetzt in andere Parteien genau die
ärgern sich
wahnsinnig darüber was ihnen in einer
Zeit mit hoher Inflation und auch eine
echten Sorge über das morgen zugemutet
wird haben sie sich überfordert haben
Sie erst die Bürger überfordert dann das
Parlament und eigentlich auch die Ampel
nein ich glaube wir haben als Ampel
natürlich eine Situation wo wir im
letzten Jahr waren ziemlich viel
Krisenmanagement hatten das haben wir
gut hinbekommen und wo wir übrigens auch
an vielen Stellen große Reformpakete auf
den Weg bringen ich denke an das
Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz ein Thema
das über jahrzehntenwerk umstritten war
das jetzt endlich auf den Weg gebracht
wird aber es stimmt dass wir auf dem Weg
dorthin zu viel uns mit dem selbst
beschäftigen und das kommt draußen zu
recht schlecht an ich glaube es kommt
wahrscheinlich auch schlecht an wenn ich
jetzt wieder sagen müssen weniger
streiten was haben die Leute jetzt auch
schon hundertmal von verschiedenen Ampel
zusammen ich gerne noch mal und Frage
ausgerechnet das ist in diesem ersten
entworfen überhaupt nicht berücksichtigt
gewesen der stand für alle 40 % und wir
wissen jetzt eigentlich immer noch nicht
aber wie konnte auch eine Ricarda lang
das Zulassen also erstmal gibt es jetzt
einen klaren Plan das heißt für alle 30
20 wenn ich besonders früh Handel noch
mal 30 wenn ich einen geringeres
Einkommen habe unsere 40.000 gedeckelt
bei 70%, die Deckung die gerade
angesprochen wurde es nur die
Anschaffungskosten nicht die sanier
Kosten dafür kannst du mal zusätzlich
Geld geben aber ja es stimmt dass ich
auch sagen würde und das habe ich ja
auch immer wieder kritisiert das war ein
Problem dass die soziale Förderung nicht
am Anfang stand ich glaube das ist auch
eine Lehre die wir auf jeden Fall als
grüne mitnehmen ich hoffe auch alle aus
der Ampel dass wir in anderen Zukunft
nicht erst über die Belastungen sprechen
dann über die Entlastung sondern
Entlastung klar sein muss aber
vielleicht nicht Einsatz noch wenn wir
jetzt wenigstens soziale Gerechtigkeit
reden dann würde ich gerne auf dem Weg
nach vorne nehmen denn da gibt es noch
verdammt viel zu tun bundestarif
treuegesetz ist ein Thema kein
staatliches Geld verloren dumping das
heißt wir haben noch wirklich einiges
vor wenn es um sich sozialgerichtlich
Einchecken da wundert man sich auch das
hätte die Ampel gleich mitmachen können
denn es ist ja eigentlich kein
schlechter Gedanke dafür zu sorgen
wenigstens in staatlichen Unternehmen
aber das werden wir bekommen bin ich
absolut überzeugt okay warum fällt wir
sind noch mal bei der Frage besseres
Gesetz wäre das ein besseres Gesetz
gewesen hätten wir dann jetzt 10% AFD
weniger
also ich glaube dass dieser Streit diese
heckhard und die nicht
erklärungsfähigkeit dieses Gesetzes dazu
geführt hat dass die AFD heute da steht
wo sie steht oder mit zu beigetragen hat
ich glaube aber der Hauptgrund warum die
AFD gerade so hochgeht in den
Umfragewerten ist dass die erlebte
Wirklichkeit der Menschen nicht
übereinstimmt mit der von der Politik
erzählten Wirklichkeit also muss konkret
zu machen was erleben die Menschen die
Menschen erleben Inflation sie erleben
hohe Energiepreise die mittelständischen
Unternehmen hat gerade eine Umfrage
ergeben 13 Prozent haben ihre Produktion
ins Ausland verlagert 30 weitere Prozent
denken darüber nach und wir machen
Kanzler der erzählt es wird ein grünes
Wirtschaftswunder geben und es wird wie
in den 50er und 60ern sein dann haben
wir eine Koalition erlebt die sich
ständig gestritten hat die selbst offen
öffentlich ihre Handlungsfähigkeit in
Frage gestellt hat und dann haben wir
ein Kanzler der sagt in Interviews jetzt
gerade am Wochenende
das Vertrauen bei uns ist groß und
menschlich kommen wir alle prima
miteinander klar und wenn das Erlebte
der Menschen mit dem erzählten von der
Politik nicht zusammen geht dann haben
wir ein Vertrauensproblem und schaffen
Frust und dieser Frust entlädt sich
gerade in dem die Menschen
oder indem wir die hohen
Zustimmungswerte zur AFD sehen und die
Union schafft es nicht ein ein
Alternativprogramm anzubieten und ich
glaube dass viele auch nicht vergessen
haben dass die Union 16 Jahre lang
dieses Land regiert hat und von der
Substanz gelebt hat und die
Herausforderung die jetzt da sind auch
da sind weil in den
unionsregierungszeiten zu wenig getan
worden ist hohe Ziele gesteckt was das
Klima angeht und so aber dass du ihn das
liegt jetzt tatsächlich bei der Ampel
ich bezweifelte dass wenn ich das mal so
sagen darf
unmittelbar zusammen eine Analyse die
Ampel streitet sich der Streit wird vor
allem an dem heizungsgesetz festgemacht
und deswegen hat die AFD zugewinde das
ist echt gerade nicht immer aber es ist
halt schon so ein öffentlicher Diskurs
der da ist und ich will schon noch mal
deutlich sagen ich würde ich würde mir
wünschen dass er jetzt nicht mehr über
Verfahren und Streit über das
heizungsgesetz sondern wirklich mal über
ein paar Sachen reden die jetzt auch
unmittelbar anstehen und im Übrigen
gehört zur ganzen Wahrheit auch in der
Tat Herr Dobrind das müssen sie jetzt
mal ertragen
also in der großen Koalition in der
großen Koalition hat es im übrigen auch
haufenweise Gesetzesverfahren mit
verkürzten Fristen gegeben also so neu
ist das nicht und in der jetzigen
Situation warte ich in und und
im übrigen erwarte ich ehrlich gesagt
noch auf das wirkliche Wirtschafts- und
industriepolitische Programm der Union
das würde mich wirklich rasend
interessieren also dann aber sich darauf
zurückzuziehen dass man sagt es ist ja
auch eine interessante Steigerung ja von
ideologischen Feind zum politischen
Gegner das ist eine interessante
Staffelung ich würde ja umgekehrt sehen
und dann und dann die Diskussion ist ja
warum die AFD solche Zuwächse hat aber
sie können auch gerne noch 50 Fragen
stellen ich wäre trotzdem den Satz zu
Ende machen
die Tatsache dass wir sowohl bei Markus
Söder als auch bei Friedrich Merz und
ich kann das nur als Empfehlung
weitergeben eine Auseinandersetzung
haben die auf den völlig wahnsinnigen
Kulturkampf der AFD abhebt die den
Leuten erzählen will es gäbe eine
Herrschaft in dieser Republik die
angeblich ihn vorschreiben will was Sie
essen wie sie leben wie sie heizen wie
sie Autofahren sollen oder sonst
irgendetwas darauf einzusteigen das ist
Wasser auf die Mühlen der AFD das gehört
auch zur ganzen Wahrheit dazu ich kann
nur empfehlen und zwar an alle
demokratischen Volksparteien und die
sich also etwas verstehen lassen Sie uns
diesen ganzen Quatsch jetzt über
Verfahren und Streit und sonst viel
weiteren klugen Punkt
nämlich genau diese Frage zu stellen wie
vermeidet man das ist sowohl ein
Regierungshandeln als auch eine
Opposition gibt die offensichtlich so
für Unzufriedenheit unter den Bürgern
dieses Landes auszubauen dass die Ampel
keine Mehrheit mehr hätte und übrigens
die Oppositionspartei cdu/csu auch nicht
in der Lage wäre jetzt eine Regierung zu
das ist doch eine Unzufriedenheit die
man thematisieren kann und da haben sie
macht sich nicht alleine am heizgesetz
Fest überhaupt nicht aber irgendwo
mussten wir ja anfangen Frau fahimi und
leider hat uns diese zeitungsgesetz
länger befasst als wir wollten wir sind
alle ein bisschen heiß gelaufen dass
ich gerne dazu so und jetzt ist die
nächste Frage worin besteht der Beitrag
der Opposition der CDU CSU um genau zu
vermeiden dass aus einer
Stimmung in einem Krisen geprägten Land
tatsächlich mehr wird nämlich eine
erstarrte AFD so also erstmal damit man
das nicht so stehen lassen
muss es ja nicht einfach stehen lassen
weil es ist ja so versucht worden
darzustellen dass man hört mal jetzt auf
zu erklären dass der Anstieg der AFD
irgendwas mit schlechter
Regierungspolitik in Berlin zu tun hat
natürlich gibt's Zusammenhänge die AFD
seit der Bundestagswahl bis heute hat
sich fast verdoppelt woraus soll sich
denn sowas erklären außer aus einer
schlechten Regierungspolitik die
Menschen fühlen sich
darauf ich komme gleich darauf so und
jetzt haben wir eine maximale
Polarisierung inzwischen in diese
Gesellschaft gebracht sag jetzt mal wir
ehrlicherweise geht es natürlich mit der
Ampel nach Hause die Menschen fühlen
sich in ihre finanziellen
Leistungsfähigkeit durch dieses Gesetz
bedroht und ich kann das nachvollziehen
wie man 15.000 Euro anbietet mehr ist es
nicht an Förderung und sagt das kann
aber für dich jetzt 50 60 oder mehr
tausend Euro bedeuten dann fühlt sich
ein Großteil der Menschen in ihrer
Existenz mit bedroht eine
heizungsanschaffung ist mit das teuerste
was jemand im Laufe seines Lebens macht
und damit hat er nicht gerechnet das
geht nicht um die Neubauten da geht's um
die bestandteilungen und an der Stelle
dann zu sagen mit Verlaub verlangt ja
aber da gibt es jetzt der Deckel stimmt
zwar mit 15.000 da gibt es noch
irgendwas anderes nein in ihren
Förderinstrumenten steht bisher nichts
anderes drinnen und deswegen werden die
Leute auch weiter Angst haben und wer
sich in seiner Existenz bedroht während
Moment wer sich in seiner Existenz
bedroht fühlt und feststellt dass auf
seine Sorgen nicht ausreichend
eingegangen wird in der Politik und dass
man sich streitet anstatt über seine
Anliegen zu diskutieren der entwickelt
eine innerliche Wut der entwickelt eine
innerliche Wut die zu Protest wird und
jetzt sage ich Ihnen warum landet das
nicht bei CDU und CSU wir sind keine
klassischen Protestparteien die Union
ist keine Protestpartei wir sind eine
Partei in der Mitte der Gesellschaft und
bei einer maximalen Emotionalisierung
der Menschen dann suchen die sich andere
Wege bei denen sie ihren Protest bündeln
können bei denen sie ihren Protest
aufheben wollen deswegen müssen wir
aufhören und vor allem auch die Ampel
bitte aufhören diese Leute so zu
emotionalisieren das ist das Grundübel
nicht verstehen
die können Demokrat mir Demokraten nur
Sorgen machen dass man so eine Situation
als demokratische Partei nur mit dem
Finger auf andere zeigt und sagt wir
machen alles richtig und die anderen
sind Schuld wir müssen uns doch jeder
jetzt überlegen welche Verantwortung
trägt auch die eigene Partei und ich
glaube was man ganz stark sieht
innerhalb der letzten Monate ist das die
AFD vor allem dort gewinnt wo es eine
Art rechten Kulturkampf um eigentlich
wirtschaftliche soziale Fragen gibt und
das haben wir in den letzten Monaten
erlebt und ich glaube um den
entgegenzuwirken muss die Regierung mehr
Sicherheit geben da müssen wir uns an
der eigenen Nase fassen gerade bei den
Fragen muss aber auch die Opposition in
dem Fall die CDU und CSU aufhören diesen
Rechten Kulturkampf wie durch Auftritte
in Erding Claudia Pechstein Begriffe wie
heizstabzieht noch selbst zu befeuern
und und das ist glaube ich deine Aufgabe
die alle Parteien haben gerade in diesen
sozialen Fragen mehr Sicherheit zu geben
ich finde da gab es einen großen Erfolg
im letzten Wochen der total
untergegangen ist die Angleichung der
Renten zwischen Osten West großer
wichtiger Schritt aber da muss noch mehr
aber es ist jetzt ein sehr bekanntes
Manöver anstatt zu überlegen was kann
man an der eigenen Politik besser machen
zu erklären die Opposition und
Stilfragen zu stellen
korrekt seinen Fragen liefern die haben
keine einzige keine einzige Kritik
angenommen Sie haben nur darüber geredet
was die Ampel falsch war ich habe gerade
zwei Punkte bezüglich der Regierung
zum besserungsvorschläge gemacht wie man
beim heizungsgesetzter Ergebnis kommen
kann was die Leute nicht dazu zwingen
geholfen wenn ich das mal sagen darf in
der 13 Woche in der 13 Woche nicht einen
echten Clou zu liefern nämlich das ganz
schlau wäre eine kommunale wärmeplanung
vorzuschalten bevor sich jeder dritte
Bürger dieses Landes eine ratternde
Wärmepumpe an seine balkontrolle
Opposition sondern die Regierung kann
überall ich dachte jetzt ich wollte nur
von meinem Leben darüber dass man die
Dinge zusammen denken
ist doch irgendwie total schön und jetzt
halten wir Sie vor ja das ist ich wollte
sagen dass eben ganz untergegangen ist
weil der Kernpunkt den sie gemacht haben
das ist und das stimmt eigentlich völlig
mit allen überall auf was sie gerade
gesagt haben wenn du wenn das letzten
Endes die Lebenswirklichkeit der Leute
die entscheidet in welche Richtung man
sich bewegt und das kann man jetzt noch
so anschüren die Unzufriedenheit indem
man den politischen dezent und die
Policierung fördert oder man kann halt
auf die Lösung zu gehen aber diese
Lebenswirklichkeit der hat mit den
ganzen Schuhe Zuweisung nicht unbedingt
was zu tun es kann auch einfach ein Boom
geben da ist die Lebenswirklichkeit
besser die Leute werden wieder gewählt
da gibt's sehr überzeugende Studien zu
uns dann gibt's eine Rezession die
Politik haben alles perfekt gemacht wenn
ich wieder gewählt und deswegen sich um
zu fragen besten Lebenswirklichkeit wird
wie dadurch beeinflusst einschließlich
dieser heizungsgeschichte und das war
jetzt der rote Teppich zu einem sehr
klugen Gedanken weil ich genau Ihnen
dazu noch einen kleinen Einspieler zeige
und dann diskutieren wir sowas
die hohe Inflation frisst uns die Haare
vom Kopf die Lohnerhöhung landet in der
Ladenkasse
Lebensmittel sind zum Teil deutlich
teurer geworden die Folge Konsumenten
halten sich zurück das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt schrumpft die
deutsche Wirtschaft ist im Abschwung in
der oecd-prognose für dieses Jahr liegt
Deutschland mit 0% Wachstum nur einen
Platz vor Russland weit abgeschlagen
Hinterindien und China
das Gespenst der deinustrialisierung
wabert über Deutschland
Rezession Investitions Zurückhaltung
Rückzug sind inzwischen dauernd Themen
selbst die Grünen hauen in dieselbe
Kerbe wir stecken in einer Rezession der
Bundeshaushalt bietet keine hinreichende
Antwort auf die deutsche
investitionsschwäche
so wird die Haushaltspolitik zu einem
sicherheitspolitischen Risiko
derweil grüßt der Kanzler lächelnd aus
einem Paralleluniversum
[Musik]
tatsächlich läuft es alles gerade auf
Deutschland zu
so als hätten wir es gedacht ist das
noch mal der Gedanke von Frau Rosenfeld
zu fragen wie sehr kollidiert eigentlich
die Lebens- und Arbeitswelt der Menschen
nicht nur die gefühlte Geldentwertung
sondern eine defacto Geldentwertung von
18 Prozent jetzt in zwei Jahren Frau
lang mit den Erzählungen des
Bundeskanzlers denken sie dass das eine
Lebenswirklichkeit ist die überein zu
bringen ist also ich glaube dass er
viele Menschen natürlich gerade diese
Inflation unglaublich hart zu spüren
bekommen das ist klar das sind vor allem
die Menschen die davor schon nicht so
viel hatten also die vielleicht nicht
wussten wie bezahle ich eigentlich meine
Miete die im Supermarkt davor schon
zweimal drauf geschaut haben wir haben
im letzten Jahr und wenn man sich
anschaffe es gab im Sinne von es wird
ein Winter der Wut geben dieses Land
fällt auseinander haben wir doch viel
Sicherheit geschafft mit den
entlastungspaketen aber es ist klar
gerade im Land wo schon vor dem Krieg
40% der Menschen kein Erspartes hatten
reicht es nicht von Entlastungspaket zu
Entlastungspaket zu handeln sondern wir
brauchen eine strukturelle Antworten
nicht umsonst verhandeln wir so hart um
die Kinder Grundsicherung ich glaube vor
allem wenn wir auch noch mal auf das
Thema wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
schauen auch da sind wir einigermaßen
stabil aus dem letzten Jahr
herausgekommen dafür wie hart die
Situation war aber sagen ja alle
Ökonomen wir sind noch nicht raus aus
der Krise und deshalb ist dieses
investitionsthema nämlich in die USA
schauen denn vielleicht schon duckt wir
schauen wie viel china investiert ist
jetzt die Frage in Zukunftstechnologien
zu investieren und bei diesem Wettrennen
nicht abgehängt zu werden das ist glaube
ich ganz ich kann bemerkenswert dass wie
Siegfried rußform der Präsident auch
Jürgen Trittin in den Mund nimmt dass
wir in einer Rezession sind dass die
Investitionen aus dem Land gehen also
wie auch in einer
investitionsschwäche sind das heißt da
teilt einen nicht ganz unbekannter
grüner Politiker die Einschätzung
durchaus auch der des BDS und auf der
anderen Seite haben wir einen
Bundeskanzler ich sag's noch mal der
davon ausgeht dass alles gerade auf
Deutschland zuläuft
wundert sie das als grüne Politikerin
wir bleiben bei dieser sozialen Frage
wundert es Sie wenn Olaf Scholz der
Bundeskanzler ihnen sagt dass eigentlich
alles gerade auf Deutschland zuläuft
also ich kann Ihnen sagen aus vielen
Debatten die wir innerhalb der Ampel
führen dass das auch natürlich beim
Kanzler angekommen ist dass wir eine
Situation stehen und wie gesagt gerade
stabil da steht aber ist auch darum geht
wie man die Weichen in die Zukunft
stellt dass Deutschland Chancen hat in
diesem Prozess das sollte auch niemand
von uns klein reden das sollte niemand
von uns weg reden wir können hier
riesige neue Zukunftstechnologien
anziehen dadurch dauerhaft sichere Jobs
schaffen und wir können das Verbinden
mit besseren Arbeitsbedingungen zum
Beispiel mehr Tarifbindung die Chancen
sind da aber Chancen materialisieren
sich nicht indem man nur davon redet
sondern mit dem man am Ende auch handelt
und ich glaube das ist jetzt die Frage
vor der bestehen als Ampel schaffen wir
es genug zu investieren schaffen wir es
beruhigen sie abzubauen und ihr
erneuerbaren Energien auszubauen in
welche Situation sind wir von meinem mit
dir und warum ist die Inflation in ihren
Augen so gefährlich in der wir gerade
stecken also die Situation in wir sind
es zunächst mal eine sehr viel bessere
als wir das vielleicht von einem Jahr
oder anderthalb Jahren uns noch gedacht
hätten das hat sehr vorhin auch gesagt
gerade aus der corona-krise raus
lieferkettenstörungen gibt es noch dann
kommt Ukraine Energiekrise und so weiter
Werte gedacht dass wir da sind wo wir
jetzt sind das heißt wenn jetzt immer
über das das Wort von dem grünen
Wirtschaftswunder von von Olaf Scholz
gelächelt wird was denkt er denn
zweistellige Wachstumszahlen und so da
muss man dazu sagen na gut das würden
halt nicht die zweistelligen
Wachstumszahlen die nach dem Krieg
werden aber es liegt auch daran dass wir
nicht so am Boden liegen wie nach dem
Krieg sondern sehr viel besser durch die
ganze Geschichte durchgekommen sind also
auf deutlich besseren Niveau befinden
als er das noch von einem Jahr gedacht
hätten insofern klar wir sind jetzt
nicht in der blumenphase und das ist
alles Friede Freude Eierkuchen aber so
möchte ich noch mal daran erinnern jetzt
was die Zukunft betrifft da habe ich so
ein zwei schneidiges Schwert ich stimme
völlig überein dass wir eigentlich einer
super Ausgangslage sind ganz von der
mitzuspielen bei den grünen Technologien
wir haben tolle Ingenieure wir haben
tolle Grundlagenforschung die können wir
noch viel besser nutzen wir alle
angewandte Forschung damit können wir
als Deutschland noch viel viel mehr
machen die Kapitalmärkte noch stärken
können wir das ganze vielleicht auch
endlich mal finanzieren das ist alles
hervorragend das heißt aber auch dass
nicht alles andere was wir derzeit hier
haben so bleiben kann wie es hier
derzeit ist und das ist halt das Thema
das meines Erachtens die die
Bundesregierung und vielleicht auch Herr
Scholz nicht so gerne anspricht man kann
halt nicht alle Sektoren der
Chemieindustrie und der Amade des
maschinenbaums und der Auto der
Automobilindustrie so behalten das
wissen natürlich die
Wirtschaftsunternehmen selber die
orientieren sich um aber
energieintensiven es sind auch die
klassischen Industrien und wenn man da
auf was Neues setzen will also mein
Lieblingsbeispiel ist ja immer die
Automobilindustrie ja ich hätte ja ich
bin ja immer noch tot traurig dass wir
als Autoland Deutschland nicht
diejenigen gewesen sind die ganz schlau
die Elektroauto sondern das autonome
fahren hier entwickelt haben wo wir
Ingenieuren Brand nehmen Jahre lange
Erfahrung und Weltraum haben aber als
das bitte nicht das nächste verpassen
was vielleicht zu machen in der zu
machen und so weiter
Inflation das ist so ein Thema das finde
ich das wird immer so ein bisschen zu
stiefmütterlich behandelt das ist halt
so ein bisschen weit weg man denkt
lieber entweder früher hat man
Arbeitslosenzahlen gegen Inflation
gesagt jetzt irgendwie sozial
Unterstützung vs Inflation für
skalimpulse wäre es Inflation ist
überhaupt nicht weit weg genau aber für
die politischen Entscheidungsprozess ja
das wird groß gesagt Inflation muss
bekämpft werden und dann werden da
gießkannenmäßig
fiskalimpulse ausgeschüttet die dem
natürlich völlig entgegenwirken und das
macht mir halt sehr große Angst dass wir
da nicht zielgerichtet haben bisher
vorgehen können den helfen die halt
Hilfe brauchen also genau wie sie gerade
gesagt haben bei der Inflation halt
nicht die Frage wie hoch meine
Inflationsrate ist sondern wie viel von
meinem Monat halt sowieso schon
aufgefressen ist und dann zu den Leuten
muss ich hingehen und die muss ich ganz
gezielt erreichen können und dass wir da
in Deutschland noch nicht besser
geworden sind das macht mich sehr
traurig okay also dann sind wir vor
verhindern die bei der Analyse die sie
sicherlich kennen weil sie sie auch
nicht nur kennen sondern auch vortragen
40% Menschen sind ohne Ersparnisse
Millionen Menschen sind Armen trotz
Arbeit und dann gibt es eine
mindestlohnerhöhung von 41 Cent das ist
ein wie sagt man eine Ohrfeige für sehr
viele Menschen die fleißig arbeiten in
diesem Land wie bekommt man das parallel
mit einer noch mal Inflation von 18 bis
20 Prozent in den letzten zwei Jahren
ausgeglichen tja das ist eine sehr
berechtigte Frage sie haben jetzt
gezielt nach dem Mindestlohn gefragt da
sage ich ganz klar das ist wirklich eine
eine absolute Ignoranz der Realität von
Menschen im mindestlohnsektor das
betrifft fast sechs Millionen
Beschäftigte in Deutschland und man muss
dazu sagen nach jetzigen Stand gibt es
3,7 Millionen die Arbeiten und
aufstockende Leistungen aus dem
Bürgergeld bekommen müssen das heißt was
wir machen ist eine Mindestlohn
Festsetzung die am Ende durch
steuerliche Subventionierung also eine
Art steuerlicher Kombilohn auch noch
wieder abgefangen werden muss das
totaler Wahnsinn was daran aber
besonders skandalös ist ist das halt das
Ergebnis nicht eines ist dass
tatsächlich auf gemeinsamen
sozialpartnerschaftlichen Kompromiss
beruht sondern das mini-angebot der
Arbeitgeber durchgedrückt worden ist
durch die Vorsitzende die ihre Rolle
offensichtlich nicht verstanden hat und
dass die Berechnung also es gibt ja
verschiedene Aspekte die berücksichtigt
werden sollen da gehe ich jetzt nicht im
Detail drauf ein aber jedenfalls nur ein
Aspekt genommen worden ist und das nicht
auf die 12 € sondern auf die vorherigen
10,45 € berechnet worden ist das heißt
was die Arbeitgeber gemacht haben ist
einfach die gesetzliche Entscheidung der
Anhebung auf 12 € völlig zu negieren
einfach zu missachten und zu sagen es
interessiert uns nicht und das Ergebnis
ist dass wir jetzt beim Mindestlohn ein
Euro unter dem eigentlich von der
EU-Richtlinie eingeforderten 60% median
Lohn liegen die sind mindestens
und ich kann nur an der Stelle sagen
aber es gäbe viele Sachen zum Thema
Inflation sehr berechtigterweise noch zu
sagen aber eins will ich dann in diesem
Zusammenhang schon noch mal deutlich
unterstreichen es macht eindeutig
der Mindestlohn ist immer nur eine
mindestauffanglinie gewesen und gerechte
Löhne entstehen in diesem Land nur durch
Tarifbindung und deswegen kann ich nur
ermuntern die einzige wirksame
Möglichkeit halt eben jetzt auch
wirklich für ordentliche Abschlüsse zu
sorgen ist Gewerkschaft beitreten
Tarifverträge erstreiten das ist der
einzige Weg ich merke es ist ein
wichtiger Punkt dass wir natürlich dass
das natürlich die Tarifabschlüsse die
wir gemacht haben auch genau ein solches
Instrument gegen die Inflation
beziehungsweise den Verlust von
Kaufkraft ist darum geht es ja ne es
geht wir reden ja jetzt hier nicht über
irgendwelche Zuwendungen an Superreiche
sondern ist der normale Beschäftigte in
seiner real Lohnentwicklung jetzt auch
stabilisiert wird da haben die
entlastungspakete des letzten Jahres
auch schon geholfen und trotzdem haben
wir im letzten Jahr insgesamt in Summe
trotz der entlastungspakete ein Minus
von 4% Kaufkraft was sich auf das Rätsel
das sind dann quasi die reale Löhne die
gesunken sind also nicht unbedingt die
Tarif drin aber eben im Durchschnitt und
das wirkt sich mit einem Prozentpunkt
BIP am Ende des Tages aus dazu kommt die
Energiekrise die auch noch mal vier
Prozent und genau aber jetzt sind wir
bei diesem sozialen Ding aber
angefangen haben trotzdem werden in der
Zeit nicht alle ärmer sondern es gibt
das wissen sie besser als ich Frau
Schnitzer hat das ja dieser Tage noch
mal betont auf der Grundlage von
ezb-daten gleichzeitig machen
Unternehmen übergewinne also mehr als
das was sie normalerweise kalkulieren
würden also den Gewinn auf den
Gewinnaufschlag aber ist die
Inflationsrate ist zu 45% aufgrund
dieser übergewinne zurückzuführen das
heißt wir haben eine wir haben eine
Profit getriebene Inflationsrate und
darauf muss die Politik auch eine
Antwort geben von der EU-Kommission
insofern gibt es da unter manchen
Wissenschaftlern einen kleinen Zweifel
ob die Zahl stimmt ich fasse das mal
schnell so zusammen und bin bei Herrn
Dobrindt hätte und sie haben das war
interessant ihre Kollegen von der CDU
auch zur Lösung unserer wirtschaftlichen
Situation eine
Millionärssteuer vorgeschlagen ich frage
wieder nach genau dieser Frage wo wie
kommen wir zu den investiven Mitteln die
wir brauchen die jetzt immer spärlicher
werden Zinsen wachsen Inflation wächst
und soforts an welchen Stellen würde sie
würden sie würde die Union würde die CSU
Schrauben sagen Sie diese Gedanken der
grundwertekommission der CDU eine
Millionärssteuer zu erwägen ist ein
guter oder sagen Sie das ist Teufelszeug
erstmal gibt es in Deutschland eine
sogenannte Reichensteuer schon seit
langem die ist eingepreist im
Steuersystem ich halte von diesen
Vorschlägen die an der Stelle gemacht
worden sind nichts das sind ja auch
Vorschläge die ein Prozess gemacht
worden und ich glaube nicht dass sich
die im Endergebnis so wiederfinden weil
was wir brauchen sind Entlastungen an
der Stelle und keine Steuererhöhungen
und das haben die Vorschläge auch an
anderer Stelle gemacht der jetzt in die
Steuer Entlastung
einzugehen weil wir ja Wachstum erzeugen
müssen wir haben eine Wachstumsschwäche
das ist ja noch mal sehr deutlich hier
gerade gemacht worden und zwar ist das
keine die überall gleichermaßen
stattfindet sondern wir haben diese
wachstumschwäche so wie wir sie in
Deutschland haben nicht in Europa wir
haben sie so wie wir sie in Deutschland
haben nicht in den USA von Kinder will
ich gar nicht erst mal reden so und da
jetzt kein Rezept dafür zu haben
führt natürlich dazu dass der
Wohlstandsverlust weitergeht nicht nur
der Wohlstandsverlust der vorhin am
Kühlschrank deutlich gemacht worden ist
das stimmt allerdings ja der
Wohlstandsverlust bei den kleineren
Einkommen ist besonders groß aber es
insgesamt in dieser Gesellschaft
inzwischen zu spüren und das kann man am
Schluss nur durch eine Bereitschaft für
Wachstum und wohlstandsmehrung
ausgleichen und das gehört dass wir
Investitionen in Deutschland brauchen
wir im letzten Jahr seit mit 135
Milliarden Kapital am Abwanderung die
größte abwarnung seit 20 Jahren das
zeigt auch unser Problem die
Arbeitslosigkeit steigt in Deutschland
die Insolvenzen steigen in Deutschland
und das Ergebnis der Politik gerade ist
dass man alles was Investitionen auslöst
absagt super Abschreibungen versprochen
im Koalitionsvertrag das ist etwas was
die Wirtschaft dazu bringt zu
investieren in den Standort Deutschland
abgesagt viele andere Dinge an der
Stelle auch so werden wir diese
Wachstumsschwäche einfach nicht
beseitigen können und deswegen habe ich
keinen Glauben daran dass wir dieses
Thema
Inflation Wachstumsschwäche überwinden
wenn wir nicht eine Politik schaffen die
am Schluss der Wirtschaft jetzt die
Möglichkeiten geht jeder in Deutschland
interessiert die merken das schon
brennend worin dann eigentlich der Plan
der cdu/csu bestünde vielleicht gehen
wir Ihnen noch ein bisschen Zeit und
Fragen natürlich
ganz einfach darüber reden warum reden
wir nicht über Steuer Entlastungen wir
müssen die Leute müssen wir wollen dass
die Leute in der Lage sind auch wieder
mehr zu arbeiten uns geht an der Stelle
die Arbeitnehmer wir reden von
Fachkräfte Zuwanderung aber bereits
nicht an dass die Menschen in
Deutschland mehr arbeiten
friedrichssteuer Land für Vermögen ist
Hundesteuer
zu stabilisieren
veröffentliche Investitionen tun Sie so
als ob man mit allgemeinen
steuerrechtlich
genausosenkung
Mehrwertsteuer abschaffen für alle
Lebensmittel
ich kann mir vorstellen dass wir als
Grundnahrungsmittel auch bei der
Mehrwertsteuer was machen
selbstverständlich ist ein Vorschlag ist
ein ist ein Vorschlag ist ein Vorschlag
ich komme nicht mit der Millionäre sie
sagen gerade die Millionärssteuer ich
komme mit dem Gedanken dass wir die
Überstunden der Menschen steuerfrei
stellen das ist ein Vorschlag von uns
wir brauchen Menschen die mir arbeiten
in Deutschland die die mehr leisten
wollen die die Überstunden in diesem
Land arbeiten wir haben fachkräftemang
lassen Sie uns diese Überstunden
steuerfrei stellen dann haben wir
sehr Beschäftigung dann haben wir mehr
Wachstum dann haben wir insgesamt mehr
Wohlstand so kann man an der Stelle doch
arbeiten nicht mit
ideenmäßig viele Überstunden geleistet
werden
Arbeitsstunden
wir haben die sind ja eingefordert
worden und es ist gut dass wir sie auch
diskutieren weil das ist genau die Frage
wie wirtschaften wir wieder Wachstum und
wird dieses Wachstum aus den grünen
Technologien kommt darüber reden wir
gleich aber es ist jetzt zunächst die
Frage ob die Menschen sich auch damit
überfordert fühlen könnten mit dieser
Situation jetzt im Grunde noch mehr zu
leisten damit es Deutschland wieder
besser geht und wir von diesem Platz 17
darunter kommen
uns in einem Transformationsprozess und
was jetzt auch klar wird die Ermittlung
dass der Weg in eine
CO2-neutrale Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft
über eine frische grüne Blümchenwiese
geht und sich ganz prima anfühlt so
einfach ist es nicht wir haben jetzt
beim heizungsgesetz zum ersten Mal auch
erlebt dass es jeden einzelnen was
kosten kann und da muss man jetzt gucken
wie das abgefedert wird und der nächste
Punkt ist wenn wir beim abfedern sind
die Bundesregierung will ja zum
kommenden Jahr die CO2 Bepreisung auf 45
Euro hochziehen wie das ursprünglich
geplant weil es ist voriges Jahr
ausgesetzt worden jetzt geht man in den
alten fahr zurück und es gab mal die
Überlegung oder so habe ich das mal von
der Ampel gehört das ist ein Klima Geld
geben soll für die Bürger dafür gibt es
diesen immer genau also das der Klima
und transformationsform wird aus diesem
co2-gelder finanziert und das Geld drin
ist das wird an die Bürger
zurückverteilt und das soll animieren
zum Energiesparen das heißt wenn ich
viel Energie sparen habe ich mit der
Rückzahlung dann
etwas mehr Geld oder bekommen habe mehr
von der von dieser Rückzahlung dieser
Klima und transformationsfonds ist jetzt
so was zu Eier wollmilch legenden wie
man immer das nennt geworden weil daraus
wird alles mögliche finanziert aber das
Klimagerät redet keiner mehr es wird zum
Beispiel finanziert eine
internetship-fabrik im Magdeburg mit 10
Milliarden Euro was das mit Klimaschutz
und klimainvestition zu tun hat ist mir
nicht so klar die Bahn soll jetzt daraus
mit finanziert werden also der der Umbau
oder der die Erneuerung des
Schienenverkehrs das ähm die
Fördergelder für das heizgesetz die
sollen daraus finanziert werden also ich
finde so die ursprungsideen die es ja
mal gab und die gute Ideen waren von
denen ist irgendwie nicht mehr viele
übrig meine grünen Haushälter aber ich
muss mal sagen immer auf jeden Fall
ich muss aber tatsächlich mal sagen ich
finde zum Beispiel wenn wir uns diese
Investition bei Intel anschauen dafür
sorgt man konkret dass hier ein
Unternehmen gerade auch in
Ostdeutschland angesiedelt wird und dass
wir vor allem eine Möglichkeit haben was
Technologieführerschaft in diesen
Bereich der Chips angeht also auch ein
Thema wo es sehr sehr stark
international um Abhängigkeiten gehen
wird oder eben um Souveränitäten ich
finde da zu sagen aber optimieren
Germany das ist doch sinnvoll genauso
dass wir die Bahn besser ausbauen und
damit natürlich auch attraktiver machen
für Menschen finde ich ein riesengroßen
Beitrag zum Klimaschutz trotzdem würde
ich zustimmen das Klima Geld sollte
kommen vor allem warten wir gerade noch
auf den auszahlen Mechanismus aber da
bleiben wir beide die kleine Kritik an
der FDP weil es ist bisher noch nicht
bestimmt
jeden einzelnen Bürger zu erreichen um
ihm mit einer Steuernummer oder seine
persönlichen Konto ähnlich wie in den
USA eben einen größeren
Geldbetrag zu überweisen um Ihnen zu
entschädigen und bedanken dafür dass er
Energie spart das ist lange besprochen
ich frage mich nur wieder auf die auf
der Kostenseite wenn wir jetzt in der
jetzigen Situation Frau lang eben auch
noch mit der CO2 Bepreisung weiter
ansteigen wenn das jetzt nicht nur durch
die EU-Gesetzgebung sondern auch durch
unser nationale Gesetzgebung zusätzlich
steigt ohne dass wir wissen was
eigentlich mit den Gas und den
Strompreisen in der Zwischenzeit
passiert denn da wird die Förderung ja
Auslaufen haben wir vielleicht da noch
mit einer ganz unschönen Kostensituation
zu rechnen nein genau deshalb setze ich
mich auch für ein Klima Geld ein weil
das ja genau dafür sorgt dass das Geld
das eingenommen wird dann wieder
zurückgezahlt wird an die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger was sogar dazu führt das
hätte man alle das gleiche auszahlt das
am Ende die die weniger Geld haben
besonders stark davon profitieren das
heißt man hat da auch einen invent
muss ich da muss ich schon recht geben
also Frau Rosenfels weiß ja zu Recht
darauf hin dass das ab nächstes Jahr
noch mal besonders relevant wird und
auch hier wieder ja in die Belastung zu
laufen und die Entlastung irgendwie
erstmal zu verschieben ist keine gute
Idee das muss zusammenkommen das gehört
auch zu dem Teil wir waren bei der
Lebenswirklichkeit die sehr wird halt
die Politik auch mitgetragen von den
Menschen und das geht so nicht wir
brauchen eine Transformation in der auch
soziale Gerechtigkeit für den Einzelnen
herrschen deswegen ist das soziale Klima
Geld nicht die Antwort auf alles was
wäre ein wichtiger Faktor und der andere
Teil wäre
richtigerweise müssen wir zentral auf
die Energiepreise schauen ich kann nur
empfehlen die Strom und gaspreisbremse
zu verlängern um die mögliche
potenzielle Verunsicherung auch für die
Privathaushalte aber auch für ganz
normale Gewerbetreibenden rauszuhalten
wenn man sie am Ende nicht braucht ist
ja alles prima
Sicherheit zu geben wäre ein wichtiges
Signal und das die vor
von ihnen so alte Industrie genannt ist
natürlich in Wahrheit ein wichtiger
wesentlicher Motor unserer
Volkswirtschaft klassischen modernen
modernen die Inno wird auch die
hocheffizient ist und deswegen brauchen
wir zusätzlich einen industriestrompreis
jetzt fragt man sich vielleicht warum
sagt eine Gewerkschafterin was zum
industriestrompreis naja weil es uns in
unserem Interesse ist nachhaltige
Wirtschaftsstrukturen aufzubauen und
Arbeitsplätze zu sichern das große ABER
liegt jetzt an einem Punkt ist der
Unterschied auch zu ich sag mal 10
Milliarden Schiff Fabrik
das muss mit Konditionen verbunden sein
das muss mit einer
transformationsverabredung die auch mit
uns getroffen wird verbunden sein damit
klar ist keine dauersubvention
Entschuldigung aber dieser Teilzeit mir
würde sagen eine Form
klugerpreis hat sich die Regierung hier
vorgenommen dir würde sagen nicht jede
Energie intensive Industrie hoppla wird
überleben in diesem Land das meinte sie
noch mal fragen ich glaube das meinte
sie doch in der Tat denke ich dass wir
das ähm ja sie alle politischen Bereich
vielleicht nicht aber ich würde mir
wünschen wenn das auf einer
ausgesprochen wird und das ist jetzt
auch nicht ganz so dramatisch wie es
leicht abklingen lassen das haben wir ja
schon mal in den 70er Jahren erlebt ja
das in Deutschland als irgendwie
Energiepreise auf einmal sehr hoch geht
die Industrien sehr gut verstanden aber
okay vielleicht ist diese Produktschiene
jetzt nicht mehr so sinnvoll vielleicht
muss ich an meiner Technologie irgendwie
noch etwas trinken lernen sich um mehr
sogar die Automobilindustrie über die
vorhin geweint hat
Leute die orientiert sich um und VW
investiert in Batterien und so weiter
aber es wird halt nicht ganz ohne
Schmerzen gehen das sehe ich schon so
wenn wir Wachstumsraten erziehen wollen
wenn wir weg wollen von dem wo wir
gerade sind dann können wir halt die
Komposition unser Industrie nicht so
lassen ich kann damit ich kann damit
völlig ich kann damit völlig da ich kann
damit völlig da Chor gehen wenn es darum
geht zu sagen natürlich heißt eine neue
moderne nachhaltige Wirtschaftsstruktur
auch das ist da drin Innovationen geben
muss und nicht alles was wir machen ist
immer innovativ aber aber der
Unterschied ist und deswegen das ist in
Deutschland anders als in den USA wir
haben eine Industrie die hochverbunden
miteinander ist und wo wir von
Grundstoffen Aluminium
kupferstahlgrundstoffe welches Gesicht
ich sehe sondern
da drin liegen nein ich will damit nur
sagen da drin liegen hohe Effizienzen
auch wirtschaftlicher Art natürlich ist
die Frage warum müssen Dinge in
Deutschland Ammoniak produzieren ja aber
wenn ja natürlich aber das ist zu kurz
gegriffen zu sagen das macht okay das
macht ja nichts wahnsinn das macht ja
nichts das rauszunehmen weil in Wahrheit
eine ganze Linie rausgeschnitten wird
das heißt wir reden nie alleine von
Ammoniak aber wie können wir so an wie
neu
aber
chip-fabrik in Magdeburg wird dann eine
neue Linie dazu komme
so einfach können Sie Leute nicht auf
dem Schachbrett hin und her schieben so
nach dem Motto von heute auf morgen
passieren muss ich sage nur
aber
gerade
auch nur dass wir eine Brücke brauchen
in der Veränderung natürlich am Ende
auch notwendig ist und rauskommt aber
wir können jetzt nicht einfach beliebige
Schnitte machen